science magazine presents a special
issue each year on the scientific
breakthrough of the year in 2010 it's
the first quantum machine
this year's breakthrough of the year is
the advent of the first primitive
quantum machine physicists took a tiny
jiggling device and put it into motion
in ways that can only be described by
the weird rules of quantum mechanics
this is a breakthrough because no one
had ever put a human-made object into a
quantum state of motion before and it
opens up a number of tantalizing
possibilities including the possibility
of testing the bounds of quantum
mechanics and our sense of reality so
for instance quantum mechanics says that
in principle a person could be in two
places at the same time or you should
according to quantum mechanics be able
to walk through walls
for physicists the weird thing is not
that tiny objects of being the weird
rules of quantum mechanics but that
larger objects don't as physicists we
believe that the laws of quantum
mechanics provide us with the
fundamental description of the physical
universe
and even though in the early decades of
quantum mechanics it was widely believed
that these laws would really only apply
to tiny objects like photons and
electrons and atoms more recently
there's been a dawning realization that
the laws of quantum mechanics and
quantum behavior should apply to objects
regardless of their size so to show that
quantum mechanics applies to a
mechanical system especially one that
maybe is big enough that you can
actually see it would I think underline
the non-intuitive nature of quantum
mechanics and further could perhaps show
that quantum mechanics applies to very
very large systems ones that approach
our everyday existence and so that was
really the driver behind trying to do
quantum mechanics experiment on a large
mechanical system the advent of tiny
quantum machines like this raises the
possibility that someday somebody might
actually be able to test these ideas by
trying to put an object in two places at
the same time that's still a long way
away but getting this key first step of
reaching the ground state really raises
that possibility the basic laws of
physics that govern these things
would have been considered to be
perfectly well known before hands
there's a real difference between having
an system that behaves quantum mechanics
on the table in front of you and simply
theorizing about it with pencil and
paper before hand putting a mechanical
object into a quantum state of motion
isn't easy to reach a quantum state of
motion you have to take out all but the
last one or two quanta of energy and
this means making the energy of the
system very low or making it very very
cold so what we did is we said in order
to first achieve the quantum ground
state we had to look at a particular
vibrational mode of a mechanical system
so you can think of it as a string on a
violin a string on a violin will vibrate
at a certain frequency if you pluck it
and it turns out that the temperature
you have to cool that violin string to
in order to get it to its quantum ground
state is proportional to the frequency
that the string vibrates at so for
instance if you took an actual violin
and you take a string that would
normally vibrate at middle a which is
440 Hertz and you wanted to cool that
violin string to its quantum ground
state you would have to cool it to an
unbelievably low temperature a
temperature that's far below what
anybody has ever achieved for any sized
system so what we said is we said well
let's take the equivalent of a violin
string but let's make its frequency
roughly a million times higher than a
standard violin string meaning that the
temperature you have to cool at two is a
million times higher and such that it's
a temperature that you can actually
achieve so that was the first innovation
was to look at a vibrational mode that's
sufficiently high in frequency up in the
microwave band that we could cool it to
it's quantum ground state I think it
would be fair to the cleveland group's
work to say that there's nothing
remarkable in taking an object that
vibrates six billion times a second
sticking it inside of a commercial
dilution refrigerator cooling it to 15
or 20 millikelvin and knowing that it's
in its ground state versus
with its in its ground state the
remarkable thing that the Cleveland
group did that no one had been able to
do before was to actually verify that
the object was in its ground state any
physics experiment on any object
necessarily will include some kind of
measuring equipment so for instance if
you kick a ball and you say well it's
behaving completely classically you have
to look at that ball to see what it's
doing in other words you have to shine
light on it and see what the light tells
you about what that ball is doing so for
example if I were to try to look at
let's say a violin string in its quantum
ground state and I did this by shining a
light on it and then looking at what the
light did I would completely destroy the
the ground state behavior of that violin
string so I can't look at it with light
instead I need to use something that I
can look at the system with without
disturbing that quantum ground state
nature they stuck with the idea of
driving the frequency of the oscillator
up as high as possible but they
developed a special kind of oscillator
that was easier to track where is in the
past other oscillators simply moved and
and researchers tried to detect the
motion by measuring the voltage between
the vibrating beam and an electrode this
team developed an oscillator that
actually expanded and contracted and
because of the material that was made
out of it produced an electric field
when it did that and that electric field
was easier to detect there are a few
physicists who have objected that this
isn't a purely mechanical system because
the researchers were tracking the
electric field that was produced by
theirs their device as it expanded and
contracted that's a valid point it's not
a purely mechanical system however as
Galileo legendarily once said and yet it
moves I think there's very little
question that the device is actually
moving and that the physicists have
controlled its motion in a quantum
mechanical way it's a valid point but I
don't think it's an important one
the oscillator that the cleveland group
studied involves the motion the
breathing like motion of a solid plate
of material inhaling and exhaling if you
like and each time it inhales and
exhales energy is stored in the
mechanical deformation of that object
now in the particular material that the
cleveland group studied a little bit of
energy is also associated with
electrical charge that builds up during
the course of that motion but it's only
about one or two percent of the energy
so one can safely say that this
oscillator is 98 or 99 percent
mechanical the quantum ground state that
we were able to cool our mechanical
resonator to is in a sense the most
boring state because it's the one that
has essentially no energy in it or no
energy that you can measure however you
have to achieve that if you want to then
really know what your system is doing
it's in a sense the fiducial state for
your system once you're in the ground
state you can then build up other more
complicated and perhaps more interesting
States from that starting point the
researchers actually went to key step
farther and achieved a few more
complicated states of quantum motion for
instance they were able to feed in
exactly one quantum of energy into their
oscillator and to put it into a subtle
state in which it was simultaneously in
the ground state and in that first
excited state a kind of energy analog of
the two places at once quantum state and
so what we're actually trying to do now
is to use our mechanical quantum system
to encode quantum information in visible
light and thus be able to perform
quantum communication between quantum
computers this is important because if
you are interested in using the quantum
properties of light for quantum
information processing or related ideas
then you live in a world in which you
have a choice between two very different
robust and mature technologies one
associated with microwaves and one
associated with visible or near-infrared
light
and by and large these two technologies
can't talk to each other they can't
transfer information coherently between
their two domains there's a lot of
interest in the idea of its quantum
mechanical mechanical oscillators might
be able to achieve coherent transfer of
information between microwave and
optical domains so that's an example of
a kind of application that this kind of
result might lead soon so while it
should in principle be possible for a
person to be in two places at the same
time the probability for seeing that is
vanishingly small and you would pretty
much never expect to see it the same
applies to walking through a wall in
principle you should be able to do it
but the probability that anytime that
you run into a wall you would actually
pass through it is exceedingly small
you'd have to run into a wall far too
many times to actually validate that
quantum theory is correct
sciences po
by Triple A us the Science Society